>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> I could not be happier to have
everyone here, and please join me
in welcoming Fiona McCrae, Tom
Sleigh and Juan Felipe Herrera.
[ Applause ]
>> Fiona McCrae: I'm
going to clap for you two.
[Applause] We're going to start
with a reading from each poet.
>> Tom Sleigh: Fiona
asked us to read
about five minutes, so
that's what I'll do.
And I always like to start with a
new poem, so that's what I'll do.
That, you know, kind
of keeps you honest.
Here it is.
Okay.
>> Fiona McCrae: Nice and loud.
>> Tom Sleigh: Can
everybody hear me?
[Laughter]
Nothing worse than sitting
there, and you can't hear a word.
Anyway, before I start, I just
want to say it's a real thrill
to be here, in this
wonderful University Club.
It's probably the first time
I've had a jacket, and I --
I mean, you know, I'm
all very spiffed up.
I just want to say that it's
a great delight to be here
with my old pal, Fiona McCrae.
I want to thank Jim and the
unbelievably dapper and suave Rob
for making this thing happen.
You know, I also, you
know, organize events,
and I know how difficult
they are to put together.
And I'm really delighted to be here.
And I also want to say
what a pleasure it is
to be with Juan Felipe.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Thank you.
>> Tom Sleigh: And I'm just
glad to be with all of you here.
I know a lot of friends
in the audience.
And Matt, thank you.
Josh Fosterguard [phonetic],
thank you.
And that's it.
Won't be any more thanks.
It's all downhill from there.
So I'm going to read a poem
that's in five short parts.
And this poem comes
out of some journalism.
I don't really know
how to put it anymore.
I've done a lot of journalism over
the years, starting around 2007
in the Middle East and East Africa.
And this piece just comes
out of having been --
about a year, two years ago
just before Libya fell apart,
traveling around with the
militia, all over the country.
And I know you say
the word "militia,"
and everybody goes, "Ohhh, militia."
You know, but everybody in this
room would be in a militia.
So it's a very, very common thing.
And when you move through
different parts of Libya,
you move from one militia's command
to another militia's command.
And that's just how you circulate.
And so when I was there
I met a young man,
a militia meter [phonetic]
who fought in the revolution
that overthrew Gaddafi, and
he had been seriously wounded.
He had a big scar on his
cheek which deformed his face.
And I was just thinking about
what it would be like to be him.
And I kept looking at his scar
and thinking it was a certain kind
of writing on his cheek,
kind of calligraphy.
So anyway, the poem is in
five parts, like I said.
One. Once I cleared the choppers,
wop-wop-wop, the airstrip opened
up into a treeless drift of sand,
where I heard a distant hammer tap
against the wind and smelled
scorched concrete wafting
from shell holes in the runway.
Then we were speeding along
in the back of an open truck,
its axles shuddering over
hardpan, as I rubbernecked
at burned-out tanks, turrets
blown to the roadside,
seeming somehow sadder
that the men who died.
Two. Just a boy who played
soccer until the revolution,
he learned with a bad
shoulder how to fire an AK-47,
shoot off of mortar so he didn't
burn his hands, talk away fear.
The radio broadcasting endless
hero victim chatter sent him racing
behind a wall, hiding from
the sniper's crosshairs.
Pinwheeling shrapnel sent them to
the hospital, where he suffered
as much from boredom as his wound.
Playing with a lizard he holds by
the tail, the panting ribs pulse
as he dangles it head-down.
His bandaged cheek crisscrossed
with tape, looking like it aches.
The hot breeze dries sweat from his
face as the lizard whiplashes loose,
scrambling across the sheet
to disappear under the bed,
one wounded foot leaving
pinpricks of blood.
Not a trail or code, just the tail
left dangling in the boy's fingers,
as he laughs and, swinging
it around,
shows it to his mother,
frowning, "What's that?"
And snatches it away.
Three. Each time the boy, grown
up now, is forced to flash ID,
his scar tissues calligraphy
writes on his body the history
of his own scalloped, twisted flesh.
Shrugging off my pose
of objectivity.
Shrinking, puckering, the skin
grafts on his burns shine white
as phosphorus in the sun.
And whatever I write down,
the counter text scrawled
on his cheek revises itself each
time his mouth flexes into a grin
or frown, as year by year whatever's
written there gets that much harder
to decipher that much
further from the war.
Until in the mirror, he'll see
and won't see his own scars.
Four. In shade and sunlight, the
lizard grows a new tail that writes
in dust over a broken
cobble, its slithering trail
until it stops short, heart pulsing
in its throat, red eyes fixed
on that foreign shape which
takes out a notebook, scribbles.
Green and brown skin, broken
black diamonds arranged
in vertical stripes, claws that
look like hands of a fever victim.
And then scribbled
notes and neutral tones
about mortar fire, flak jackets.
The strap on the helmet that is
always too lose or too tight.
The boy's bombed house,
shockwaves blowing
out the windows to let in riot gas.
An adrenaline rush.
The smell of tears, chemical
as ammonia and as harsh.
Five. All around me, the
sound of men sleeping.
Their bodies shifting
slightly in their dreaming.
The engines of the
trucks still cooling,
giving off little ticks and pings.
And then I was climbing
out of my blankets to slip
under the tent's canopy, stumbling
away from mumbling and snores.
The desert cold making
the dew-damp sand stiffen
so it crunched underfoot, as I crept
beyond the watchman to take a piss.
And at the edge of the camp near
the chickens and their coop,
heads tucked under wings
was a fox staring back.
Or what I thought was a fox,
ducking down into the shadows
and disappearing behind the trucks
that in the morning would obliterate
its precise four-clawed tracks.
But the next night and the
next would keep on coming back,
until the chickens got eaten
or the fox was killed.
Then pattering of my own piss
brought me back into the cold.
The sky overhead, dark and bright.
Bundled bodies in the dawn
beginning to levitate.
Whose elbows dreamed
up the chokehold?
Who pushes back the boundaries
so that no man's land is the only
high-bond [phonetic] homeland,
patree [phonetic]?
Who strips us of our shadows so
that our histories turn to glass?
And then it was time for breakfast.
To sit, pee, smoke and take my place
besides the others in the truck.
Then I'll finish with
a short poem from my --
I don't know what to call her.
You know, she came into
my life via divorce.
So I'm not really her biological
dad, but I feel like her dad.
So we have this little code.
I'm her dear almost dad, and
she's my dear almost daughter.
So we're both each other's dad.
That works.
Second Sight.
In my fantasy of fatherhood,
in which I'm your real father,
not just the almost dad arriving
through random channels of divorce,
you and I don't lie to one another.
Shrugging each other off when
words get the best of us,
but coming full circle
with wan smiles.
When you hole up inside
yourself, headphones
and computer screen taking you
away, I want to fill in ten years
that if I'm still alive,
you'll still look at me
with that same wary expectancy, your
surreptitious, cool-eyed appraisal,
debating if my love for you is real.
Am I destined to be
those shark-faced waves
that my death will one
day make you enter?
You and your mother make
such a self-sufficient pair.
In thrift stores, looking for your
prom dress, what father could stand
up to your unsparing eyes,
gauging with such erotic calculation
your figure in the mirror?
Back of it all, when I
indulge my second sight,
all I see are dead zones.
No grandchildren, no evenings at
the beach, no bonfires in a future
that allows one glass of
wine per shot of insulin.
Where we both agree that I love you
always, no matter my love's flawed,
aging partiality, my occupation
now is to help you be alone.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That was beautiful.
>> Tom Sleigh: Thanks.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That was beautiful.
Again, thanks, everybody.
I really appreciate being
here at the University Club,
and I really enjoyed
our conversations.
We had some conversations
about possible projects
already and using video.
And so I just want to tell Rob that
there's more projects coming up.
[ Laughter ]
And things really began
to happen for me
when you came in, and
we had -- we met.
So thank you, and also Tom
and Fiona, and the whole team.
Thanks again.
You know, I'm like you, you
know, I have a fresh poem,
and I've been deciding --
>> Tom Sleigh: Read it.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Whether to
read it or read this or read that.
So it's kind of like
the tradition, isn't it?
To bring out a poem
that we just wrote.
And I don't know why we
really do it, but we do.
It's kind of -- I don't know.
It just -- that's what we do.
Is that strange?
It's a strange little thing.
We've got, you know, a ton
of poems already ready,
published, and the whole thing.
And here we go, you know,
with a poem that we
just typed this morning.
So Victor Martinez was a
really good friend of mine,
a meticulous poet and writer.
And he got the National Book Award
for Parrot in the Oven in 1996.
And he got it by just cracking
each line into little pieces
and just really worked so hard
on the language and the story
and everything you
could ever imagine.
Every word in that book is
measured and weighted and looked
at from a thousand angles, from
20 feet away, pinned on the wall,
and then he would literally use it.
He passed away in 2011
from lung cancer.
A lot of my good friends
have passed away
from cancer recently,
the last ten, 15 years.
And I had written him some poems
early on called Undelivered Letters
to Victor while he was alive.
So I remember him saying --
he was really a deep guy,
a really deep thinker.
And on the back of his only
poetry collection called Caring
for a House, he says quite a bit.
He writes a big old, giant
paragraph on the back of that book,
and he talks about this thing
he calls super imagination.
And who knows, you know, if it's
Quantum Theory or super imagination,
and all about being in two
places at the same time.
So I always think of him.
So this is called Thought Poem
for Victor Martinez, Undelivered.
Still thinking about super time,
super space and super imagination.
You said what you wrote
was being written
by someone somewhere
else at the same time.
Some country, some town, in a
broken bus or a polished grain desk
or a cheap clinic deep in
the rainforest somehow.
A hut fixed with branches
and strings.
Just maybe a school tilted en route
to tumbo-by-baneke
[phonetic] somewhere.
What would you be writing?
It does not matter and why.
Poetry -- why that?
Why continue its tiny
mouth on a page?
Why not a simple message,
just a message there is more
hunger than poetry, Vic.
I am pushing down the 300 buildings.
There is thirst, Vic, more
thirst than knowledge.
You always spoke of this thing,
knowledge, you read Heidegger.
What is thinking more
than knowledge?
Vic, how about knowledge
in the hand?
In the gut?
Water from a storm.
Hunger in the center of your
flesh; not flesh, is not knowledge.
It is pure insight, sinew.
It is edge.
More edge than poem paper
poems are not bread.
I am calling for bread.
With empty offices at night,
the ones across from my tenth floor
poetry bed door, D.C. Somewhere else
in the variety realms, even though
I am here, brother, and you are not.
So that's the Thought
Poem for Victor Martinez
that I hammered out this morning.
And this is Task the Void, and this
is [foreign term], and this is --
it always comes to this too --
doesn't it -- which poem to read?
I Walk Back Nowhere.
Let's do I Walk Back Nowhere.
I walk back nowhere,
under moonlight.
The dogs look as if they are angels.
The ones I never imagined,
with drooling,
silvery rays and torn behinds.
Yes, blowing in the strange
and excited phosphor,
dancing out of rhythm.
Racing up trees, chasing snails.
This is like a children's book.
Oh yes, the children with
rectangle heads and sacked stomachs,
with the eyes of Da
Vinci, sad and impish.
Meticulous as even Haldun
[phonetic] and [inaudible]
as Nietzsche, phlegmatic and bitter.
When they speak, they leave
opalescent liquids on the grasses.
Stuttered, under a half-erased
mural of [inaudible].
Or is it [inaudible]?
Wait. The children never speak.
They nod their heads.
They carry huge bundles,
strapped across their foreheads.
They weep under newspapers
and roll up their skirts
and wash them in gutters.
Ponds, if they find them.
Then they run into the sea.
This is where we meet on occasion.
We make up stories.
We'll remember fruits and produce as
if blessed by the plutonium blast.
Remember the pears?
They were so green, and the
avocados, like guitars --
honey, golden; and the asparagus,
like a lion's rainy mane,
and our mouths water.
Their mouths water.
I am used to these stories.
I am used to the land, barren,
bitten in a flame with lies.
I am used to our faces in this
new wild, dispassionate life.
I learned this from
my musician friends.
From years waging feudal
wars with poetry
until I could not think
of anything else.
[Inaudible]
[ Applause ]
Thank you, [inaudible].
>> Fiona McCrae: Thank you.
Thank you both.
So now's the chitchat time.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Chitchat.
>> Fiona McCrae: The heading for
tonight was Voicing the World --
How Poets Engage with Communities
Within and Beyond our Borders.
So as I was sitting here, I did have
a moment of enjoying the thought
of the, you know, poetry, literary
community that we're in here
and so many allies, sitting there
and just grateful to you all
and to Jim and Rob for hosting us.
Thank you both for reading.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Thank you.
>> Fiona McCrae: Juan Felipe, in
your -- somewhere in that book,
the one you just read from, is
Literary Asylums, and in it,
you write -- this is
just an excerpt from it.
You say, "The idea of an audience,
the idea itself tears
into all experience.
The assumption of an
audience, they are listening."
So I thought we might start
with community as audience
and just ask each of you what
assumptions you make about audience,
where your poems are
heading -- headed.
If any.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Well,
you know, I was always concerned
with the question of
audience, because I started --
I also started out in
theatre, kind of speak theatre,
and I always wanted to -- and
having read Antonin Artaud's book
on the Theatre of Cruelty
and his journey to Mexico
and to [inaudible] ritual and how
he became all aflame with that,
how he really got a lot
of stuff out of that.
He wanted this kind of visceral
ritual, intense, you know,
[inaudible] aflame ritual,
explosive self happening,
where his words will
just burble out.
And he was like super totally
present in this ritual, compressed,
symbolic, physical visceral moment.
So I was excited by that
back in high school.
And so I wanted to figure that
out, where there is no audience,
because there is no audience
in that world, in a sense.
So then I began to do community
theatre and political theatre,
and there was always an audience.
And I was always trying
to deal with that.
And now I visit so many audiences,
and they're all so amazing,
and they're real audiences.
And they're different, and they
ask different things of me.
And I feel all their
lives hitting me.
And I go to them, and we
kind of come together.
And in my poetry, I think --
to change my poetry, I go,
"I'm going this way, but
you're pulling me this way.
You know, I want to write this,
but you want me to write that"
and "I have this in mind,
but you have this in mind."
You know, I feel that,
from the audience.
You know, I feel it.
I go -- I'm reading this,
you know, poem, I go --
they'll look at me, go, "Come on.
Let's move on to something,
something real.
Come on, Juan."
So I feel that, you know?
I feel that.
And they're excited and you
know they -- all these things.
And I want -- I like -- I
want to adjust, you know,
because I'm in the moment.
I'm in the moment.
So now for me it's a moment.
It's a momentarium.
I'm in that momentarium, and I
want to be in that momentarium.
Of course, I am.
Of course, we all are.
But so now my poems are
changing because of that.
>> Tom Sleigh: Well, audience,
the first thing that really came
to my mind -- I also read Artaud.
>> Juan Felipe Hererra:
Remember that?
>> Tom Sleigh: Yeah, yeah.
[Inaudible] and you know,
a lot of the poems too.
And I was always interested
in his idea
about how the actor makes a gift
of his whole being to an audience.
That was something that,
when I first came across it,
was such a different
kind of way of thinking
about just approaching what it was
you were doing, because before that,
I, you know, what the
fuck did I know?
I grew up in a tiny
town in Utah, you know.
There was no culture of any kind.
And so to come across this
and even what I thought
of as an audience was
me at the school play.
You know, and then
and then, you know,
I did some theatre work as well.
And one thing I thought
was interesting
about doing the theatre was
that, until I read Artaud,
I always thought it was
like a kind of presentation.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Yeah, a presentation,
and they're out there,
and we're over here.
>> Tom Sleigh: Yeah.
As opposed to a gift of yourself to
what was going on in their minds.
And so that's just an
interesting way to kind of segue
with what you're talking about --
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And no
boundary, breaking that boundary.
>> Tom Sleigh: Yeah, and
the boundary, exactly.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Breaking the boundary.
>> Tom Sleigh: Yeah, exactly.
And breaking down the whole idea
that when you're playing a role,
when you're playing a
part, that the audience is
in some way completely --
has suspended disbelief,
and they really think you're Julius
Caesar, where it's really, you know,
as far as Artaud was
concerned, I mean, he was Artaud,
and he was Julius Caesar
at the same time.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: He
was Antonin and Julius Caesar.
>> Tom Sleigh: So I always thought
that was an interesting,
really interesting idea.
And just in terms of writing poems,
that's the kind of
public aspect of it.
And I think Juan spoke
really beautifully to that.
But you know, just in terms of
the private aspect, you know,
when I'm sitting down, I think of
my audience as being all these --
well, all these dead people,
like, well, like Phil now.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: That's true.
>> Tom Sleigh: You know?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yes.
>> Tom Sleigh: You
know, like dead friends.
I think of those people as you
know sort of being in the same room
with me, and I don't want
their voices to be too loud.
You know?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's right.
>> Tom Sleigh: But I like
having then them there.
And so consequently, I think
that for me an audience is
this present moment here,
like Juan was talking -- Juan
Felipe was talking about.
But it's also when you're
privately by yourself,
it's like the whole community of
the dead that is speaking to you
and through you and that you're
trying to speak back to them.
And I think that's one of
the most beautiful things
about being involved in
an art form like poetry.
You know, the money is great.
We all love the money.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Big money.
There's big money.
There's a Bentley and
a Rolls Royce outside.
>> Tom Sleigh: Yeah, a Bentley
and a Rolls Royce, right.
But the thing that's
really wonderful is
that you actually have a sense
of, you know, going, you know,
it's like every poem you
write is this time machine.
And it goes both forward,
and it goes backward.
And I love the sense of connection
that that gives me to,
you know, a wider world.
Because I'm not a conventionally
religious person at all.
And it sort of makes -- and I always
think that posterity is kind of,
you know, distant from me.
And it also feels kind
of pretentious, you know,
"I'm writing my poems
for posterity,"
just like, the fuck is posterity?
You know? So it's sort of like --
but if I have the idea that in fact,
you know, I'm in this time machine,
and it's going forward, then it's --
then again, it's like that present
moment that Artaud was about.
It's a present moment in the future,
and it's also as much
present in the past.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's right.
That's -- I think that's where we
-- that's where we were headed.
Because as we're talking about
this, it all comes down to mind
as one big, juicy, spiraling mind
that goes back, forward, sideways
and in unknown directions.
And it just keeps on.
I think that's why we're writing.
So the audience was maybe just
a draft -- a draft concept.
>> Tom Sleigh: It's like that
Teilhard de Chardin had this concept
of the noosphere, in
which there was --
the entire earth was blanketed
by an atmosphere of thought --
of thinking, of spiritual endeavor.
It's a kind of a beautiful idea.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Or the universe blanket.
The universe blanket
that the Mayans had.
>> Tom Sleigh: I don't know that.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
It's a universe blanket,
and it's also with the women -- the
women's [inaudible], you know the,
when we see those nice
Indian shawls and --
they're like universe blankets.
They have the story of the universe
on them, and by wearing them,
by wearing them and moving -- you
wear it, you know, and you move --
of course, you're walking,
and you're moving around,
you're also contributing to
the motion of the universe.
So it's like a universe blanket.
And the whole notion
of [inaudible] or one
of the elder Mayan
[inaudible] in Chiapas,
and the vestiges of the rain forest.
>> Tom Sleigh: You knew him?
I know him too.
I met him when I was
doing anthropology?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
When was this?
>> Tom Sleigh: That
was back in [inaudible]
with Pepe Martinez [phonetic], the
bush pilot and Robert Bruce and --
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Robert Bruce.
He was there in the '50s.
>> Tom Sleigh: Yeah, and then I met
him when he was a pretty old guy.
He had cancer.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: In the '70s?
>> Tom Sleigh: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Or later?
>> Tom Sleigh: Well, it was just
when the Guatemalan War was --
because I was working
for Gertrude Blom.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Oh, you were?
I was there with Gertrude Blom.
[Inaudible] Yeah, it was me.
I know Gertrude.
I knew him, and I knew all his sons.
>> Tom Sleigh: I met his son,
[inaudible], and then I met --
did you know [inaudible]?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yeah.
>> Tom Sleigh: Oh my God.
You knew [inaudible]?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yeah.
>> Tom Sleigh: What
a sweet guy he was.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: A sweet guy.
That was a sweet guy.
That's right.
>> Tom Sleigh: Yeah.
I'm sorry, we're having
a conversation.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: So
we came back to [inaudible].
Remember he said that when the
youth cut a timber of [inaudible],
a star falls, because you know
you're ripping up the rainforest.
And every time you rip down or
cut down and kill or sever a tree,
you're also severing a star.
>> Tom Sleigh: I mean, this
context of this is that Juan Felipe
and I were both in
Chiapas in Southern Mexico,
maybe at more or less the same time.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
When were you there?
>> Tom Sleigh: I was there --
God, when I was probably
30-some, 35, 40 years ago almost.
Something like that.
Just when the Guatemalan
War was getting heated up.
And [inaudible] is a [inaudible].
And Gertrude Blom was kind of --
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
What a world.
>> Tom Sleigh: Yeah,
she was an archeologist.
She was a -- you know, what she
really was was a great photographer.
That's what she really was.
Yeah, and a strong force
of nature, for sure.
Did you remember -- oh, my God.
The stories I'd like to
tell about Gertrude Blom.
Oh, my God.
I remember once a woman -- she
had a kind of research center.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
She did, yeah.
>> Tom Sleigh: And anthropologists
would come from all over the world
to visit there, and the way she kind
of financed the research center --
which she also sort of
had a quasi kind of hotel.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
It was a quasi hotel.
>> Tom Sleigh: Yeah.
And people would come in,
and it was a little bit
like Fawlty Towers, right?
Yeah, so the guests would come in --
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: The Mayan --
>> Tom Sleigh: But they
had really wonderful --
they're great anthropologists
from all over the world, actually.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And
so you got into anthropology?
>> Tom Sleigh: I did, yeah.
I studied it, and that's
why I was down there.
Yeah.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: So did I.
Yeah, I got a degree
in anthropology.
Is that what you did?
>> Tom Sleigh: Yeah,
I mean, I studied it.
I mean, I did all the
[inaudible] the British guys.
Anyway, well, no, but see
I've been so interested
in that stuff for forever.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: So yeah,
so Gertrude Blom and Frans Blom --
>> Tom Sleigh: Frans
Blom, her husband.
Yeah.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: So what
was the last year you were there?
>> Tom Sleigh: The last time
I was done there was long
after Trudy's death.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Oh, [inaudible].
The late '90s?
>> Tom Sleigh: Yeah.
And then they transformed
it, you know,
and now it's taken
over by the government.
And it hadn't had --
all the aura was gone.
>> Fiona McCrae: Can
I have a minute?
Now I bring you back --
>> Tom Sleigh: I'm sorry.
>> Fiona McCrae: No, it's great.
It's funny with --
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
It's good to remember, huh?
>> Fiona McCrae: We're just sort
of looking at you both and --
not looking at you both now, but
looking at you both together --
and that's two different poets.
And then you do start to
see similarities in thinking
about this idea about
communities within and beyond,
you've both written about
places not right here or --
and you have public
subjects, in a certain way.
And you've had all your travels in
the Middle East and East Africa,
and sometimes you've
written about that
in prose and sometimes in poetry.
And then you have the book about --
a lot of your work
within the Senegal Taxi,
that I thought was
kind of interesting,
where there's prose
and poetry within that.
So I was wondering about what --
how poetry serves as a voice
to communicate about the other,
the person who's not you, how you do
that and what responsibilities come
with that, to whoever you
might be writing about
and once you start going
public, then words like duty
and someone's thought coming
in, which is a different --
when you're writing about your
inner -- you and your stepdaughter,
no one can contradict
you about that.
But if you're, if you're writing
about something that's a little
bit -- when your subject is beyond,
what does that bring up for
you and how does -- how do --
you've both written theatre.
You've both written prose.
But how do you find the form?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Well, you
know that -- I remember that --
that's a big issue, still.
But it used to be such a hard
issue back in the early '80s.
I remember we used to have
these big old hot debates --
I think poets in the schools had
these big hot debates about "Well,
you know, what, you know, you
can't write as a, you know,
a Chicano voice, because
you're not Chicano.
And you can't write, you know,
African-American voice, you know.
How dare you?"
and all that.
And we kind of liked
that concept, you know,
we were kind of grooving
with that concept.
And it was a cultural appropriation
and all that was like hot, you know?
Wrestling -- it was wrestling --
writers were wrestling on the
floors, trying to work that out.
And but then, you know, you
know, it's not a, you know,
that's kind of all said
and done now, in a way.
Because everything is crisscrossing,
and everything is changing.
A poem is a poem.
This is not a mirror.
It's not a police report.
It's not a social science tract --
even though it could be
all those things, in a way.
But it's -- you know,
it's made out of jelly.
You know, it's just perception.
And what we see is changing.
What we write is changing.
Our thoughts are changing.
Today is different than yesterday.
So there's really no
real solid appropriation.
That's one thing, for me.
And then the other thing is,
you know, you really have to --
this is going to sound
a little corny,
but you really have to feel it.
You really have to, you
know -- you may be way off,
but you really have to feel it.
And you really -- for me,
when I wrote Senegal Taxi,
I looked at National
Geographic in a dentist's office.
That was really highfalutin,
intellectual moment.
I was in a dentist's office,
and there was a National Geographic
magazine, and it was a feature
on Africa, and you know how
cool those features are --
and it was about the
[inaudible], sub-Saharan belt --
the Sahara, and right underneath
the Sahara, there was this kind
of weather belt called
the [inaudible].
And here's Sudan, way over here,
and way over here is Senegal.
And because of the atrocities
committed in Darfur in the Sudan,
people were running -- they were
massacred, but some of them escaped
and would try to go through these
big old climatic upheavals of dust
and winds and heat, and then people
grabbing whoever was migrating
or escaping and just killing them.
And these little, tight
locked, ghost --
what they call ghost
houses, with Kalashnikovs.
So you couldn't escape.
They'd grab you, throw you in
there and just torture you.
And then they had to make it all
the way to Senegal, at the very edge
of the coast, all the way
from the Sudan to Senegal.
And then from Senegal, they had to
find a little canoe or boat and try
to make it to the Canary Islands.
And then from there, they had to do
the same thing and make it to Spain.
And from there, they had to do the
same thing and make it to New York.
What a zigzag, long, impossible
journey -- a migrant journey --
escape, life or death journey.
And I said, that sure is
much different than making it
from Mexico City or any town --
even though the torture is there,
through the border, and then the
scorching South Arizona deserts,
where many migrants
die or are killed
and are taken into
freezers in Tucson.
So I was just amazed by that.
I was moved by that, and
I said, I don't know,
I don't know, this is moving me.
I don't know what's going to happen.
Then I happened to get a month at
the Montalvo Art Center in Saratoga.
We have a month to write and cook
with people and feed yourselves.
Really cool.
And so I had 30 days,
and I just wrote that.
I just wrote that piece,
no matter how it came out.
Senegal Taxi.
And I did all the things I wasn't
supposed to do, back in the '80s.
I did all the things I
wasn't supposed to do.
>> Fiona McCrae: You did lots
of different voices
throughout that book, right?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: I used
a lot of different voices.
>> Fiona McCrae: Including
Kalashnikov.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
The Kalashnikov voice,
the voice of the ant, the fly.
And on and on.
But I contradicted
myself, which felt good.
It's still problematic.
But then I was surprised, and it
may not be 100% true, but I was kind
of cautiously poetically weirdly
happy that a man from Senegal
and New York said I was in the
vicinity of weird accuracy.
The only accuracy a poem can have.
>> Tom Sleigh: Weird accuracy.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
It's weird accuracy.
>> Tom Sleigh: I agree.
Yeah. What's funny -- I'll
just say that, you know,
Robert Frost once said that, you
know, just in response to this,
because he had an idea of
cultural appropriation --
yeah, because I did, you know,
poets in new schools too.
And there was a lot of that kind
of talk around at the same time.
And it was always complicated
because --
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
It's complicated.
>> Tom Sleigh: What you
really wanted to say was --
Robert Frost did a
really smart thing once.
He said he didn't really --
the thing that he really wanted
was the freedom of his material.
And that seemed to me like if
you were a poet, that's the thing
that is most important to you.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's your thing.
>> Tom Sleigh: You know,
and so if you, you know,
if you break other
person's rules, that fine.
You know, but you know
for myself, you know,
in writing about what I feel like I
owe the people that I write about --
you know, like that
Libyan guy, for example.
You know, I was very aware
that his experience was --
I mean, in many ways it was
radically different than mine,
but in many ways it
was weirdly similar.
Because like for -- the story
that he told me about Gaddafi
and what it was like growing up
under Gaddafi was strangely similar,
because he said what would happen
was, you know, when he was a kid,
they didn't have any
television stations.
So -- matter of fact, they only had
one, really, and that was the one.
And -- but they didn't
have much entertainment.
So he was watching -- when he was a
little boy he remembered watching a
series, an animated series about
a baby bee that got separated
from its mother and
wants to find his mother.
And just as they get to the climatic
episode, Colonel Gaddafi comes on
and begins to blather
on about Pan-Africanism.
So he says there was
that element of it.
And then he said, you know, later
on there was another program
about a little boy who wanted
to become a soccer star,
and like just about the moment
he was going to make the team,
and again, last episode,
which he never got to see,
there Colonel Gaddafi is
talking about the Green Book.
So, you know, I'm really aware -- at
the same time, I'm thinking, yeah,
well I -- when I was a kid I watched
stupid television shows like that
and really got deeply invested
in them and I thought, well,
there's a kind of intersection
between his childhood
and my childhood even at the same
time as, you know, you know, I mean,
I've been in war zones, but
I never fought in a war.
Not even close.
You know what I mean?
And so the thing that I
wanted to do was in a way
when I was writing something
about him is I wanted to --
first thing to acknowledge
is, well, this is what --
there is where we have in common,
but these are the areas for me that,
you know, I just have to acknowledge
the limits of what I know.
And I think if there's a way
of building that into the poem,
then this whole issue about
-- is this your material?
Is that my material?
It just seems -- it seems silly
to me at the end of the day.
And the fact of the matter is
if you feel compelled to take
on this material, well, then you
let other people sort it out.
You know? And they will.
I mean, they will, you know.
One of the things I find really
strange right now is a kind of --
this phenomena of internet shaming,
which I just find very, you know,
very, very, you know, it's
troubling and disturbing.
And one of the things about the
-- doing the kind of, you know,
writing about subjects that
are sort of located in cultures
that are very different than
your own is just being able
to acknowledge the limits
of what you can know.
>> Fiona McCrae: In one of your
recent poems, there's a line.
Your first line is "You've
got to put your pants
on in the house of fact."
>> Tom Sleigh: Right.
Yeah, you've got to put
your pants on right.
"Put your pants on in
the house of fact."
It's a very important thing to do.
Yeah.
>> Fiona McCrae: So as
long as you kind of --
>> Tom Sleigh: Yeah.
>> Fiona McCrae: There's
something that's going back to --
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: But you
have to find the house of fact;
otherwise, your pants
will fall down.
>> Tom Sleigh: Exactly.
The house of fact is
being ruined every minute.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
But what -- you're right.
It's about -- it's about
connecting, where we can connect.
You're right.
It's about compassion and suffering.
And that's where I wanted to go.
And I didn't mess with
cultural practices.
I didn't mess with
one-dimensionality.
I wanted to make the people
we thought were terrible --
like the Janjaweed the
actual paramilitary.
So I got to bring that
character into this piece.
That's going to be impossible,
because I don't have --
I don't have any idea
about that person.
And there's nothing really
written about Janjaweed.
So how am I going to do this?
How am I do this?
Because if I leave
that character out,
I'm going to leave a big piece
out, because this is the killer.
So I've got to bring that -- I'm
going to have to challenge myself
and jump into the hot
griddle and throw myself
into boiling chili sauce.
And so I brought that
character in, in a radio show.
I threw a radio show in the middle
of the book, hosted by Bart Crimson.
And then Bart Crimson is the host,
the anchor dude who's very nasty,
and he really pushes this
guy, which I like doing that.
I like to have that pushy anchor.
You know? "Come on.
What do you mean you don't
know about those bombs?
Will you get with the story?
You know what you've done.
Just come on.
Get to the story.
Only got 30 seconds."
So I made that radio host like that,
then I made the Janjaweed more like,
"Oh well, I did have a
dream, and there were bodies,
and the chest was opened up.
The chest was open."
"Oh, so all of a sudden
you got feelings, huh?"
So then the -- so I
kind of turned --
I turned this around
as best as I could.
And I enjoyed doing that.
And that gave me a little --
a little room to bring
in those characters.
But then again, we don't know --
you know, I didn't
know where I was going,
and we don't know where we're going.
The house of fact.
>> Tom Sleigh: I went through
a poem that used, you know,
I want to do a poem in the voice
of Charles Taylor, a war criminal.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yeah.
Like that, like that.
>> Tom Sleigh: Yeah.
And so -- and so there's
a way in which you can --
I think it's really how you pitch
it, in fact, because Charles Taylor
and this poem is the sort of --
it's kind of a composite of my past,
as well as being, you know,
the historical Charles Taylor.
And it's an interesting, you know,
problem because basically
what you're trying to do is --
as far as I'm concerned, you're
trying to make a credible voice
that will fit inside a poem.
And I think that's
the important thing.
A credible voice that
will fit inside a poem.
It doesn't have to be --
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: "The" voice.
>> Tom Sleigh: Yeah, "the" voice.
But a credible voice.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And
then we don't even know --
we don't think about that.
We're not thinking.
We got the feeling for it, right?
>> Tom Sleigh: No, it's the idiom.
When you get the words and
you get the idiom right,
then you don't worry
about it so much.
Yeah.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yeah.
>> Fiona McCrae: Well, it seems like
-- from [inaudible] again, Juan,
again you're saying it's this or
throughout this conversation --
we've put this conversation.
We've gone the mind, the
material and connecting.
It feels kind of a nice --
the mind where you invent it.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
And the house of fact.
>> Fiona McCrae: In
the house of fact.
>> Tom Sleigh: One of your
[inaudible] house of fact.
>> Fiona McCrae: I think we're
ready to have Jim come back.
We thank you both very much,
and thank you all for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> It's indeed an honor to be in the
presence of two such great poets.
>> Fiona McCrae: Such
great anthropologists.
>> And my publisher.
It's my job to give the benediction,
and it will be brief, blissfully.
But I want to urge those and you
in the room to embrace the Poetry
and Literature Center at
the Library of Congress --
a great group run by a great man.
>> Fiona McCrae: Here, here.
>> And the National Council
of the Graywolf Press,
which is open to everyone.
You know, the word that I'd like
to hit on tonight with regard
to Graywolf is non-profit.
And non-profit means we
that rely very heavily
to sustain the excellent work
that Fiona and her staff do
on contributors and the
community of readers
and literature fans
around the country.
And we hope you'll embrace
the council as well,
and we'd love to have
you learn more about it.
Before you leave tonight, I think
you can still get a glass of wine,
but we also have some books
from Tom and Juan Felipe who --
I think they'll be able
to inscribe them for us,
and some catalyzed book lists for
your perusal and to take with you.
And you have my thanks for coming
to University Club tonight.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.